et donc messieurs le césar du meilleur
espoir masculin est attribué à kevin
c'est le frère de vincent rottiers qui
avait débuté au cinéma avec enel sa
partenaire dans ces combats ton sort les
hater thomas gayet dit l'avoir choisi
pour sa personnalité par petits durs en
a pas nos prix tombent dès qu'on le
connaît il a débuté au cinéma aux côtés
d'isabelle adjani c'était dans la
journée de la jupe en 2008
nous le retrouverons en 2015 dans
l'année prochaine premier long métrage
de banias le turc et la belle saison de
catherine corsini aux côtés d'israël un
nommé aussi ce soir c'est le deuxième
césar de la soirée pour les combattons
et succède au palmarès à pierre de l'add
on chante on habite à leur remettre un
prix qui avait été couronnée pour
l'inconnu du lac
à un débat déjà il est très lourd c'est
je vais poser juste je veux commencer
déjà denis podalydès je suis vraiment
ravi que ce soit y est vous qui meurent
métier le césar parce qu'on a j'ai
tourné mon premier film avec vous qui
était la journée de la jupe
je vais remercier ma maman voilà mon
papa que j'aime très fort ma famille
quoi voilà je vais je vais remercier
surtout l'équipe thomas cahier pierre
guillard david cayer voilà il ya
violette yaeyama nous il ya plein de
gens vont vraiment merci
voilà ce qu'on m'a dit préparez un truc
j'ai pas préparé je tais tu fais une
bêtise je sais voilà en tout cas
vraiment merci merci merci merci merci
merci merci merci mille fois mille fois
mille fois mille fois la profession à
ceux qui ont voté pour moi à tous les
réalisateurs qui m'ont donné une chance
de te voilà de tourner dans leurs films
de voilà de performer vraiment merci
beaucoup merci aux frères lumière voilà
qui ont créé le cinéma voilà on m'a dit
qu'il fallait que je le dise
qui vous a dit ça voilà aussi pareil
voilà je veux faire un grand merci à
tous mes amis à mon grand frère grand
sens
voilà qui sinon dans la salle ce soir et
et voilà quoi merci merci merci merci
encore une fois merci à mon agent merci
juanita fellag merci beaucoup mon agent
merci merci à stéphane battu au sikkim
hakima qui m'a repéré pour les
combattants et voilà et puis bah merde à
tous tout le reste des nommés voilà et
merci beaucoup